okay let's follow up on a couple of
different stories that we've been
covering for some time you might
remember that sort of in the in the
middle of uh the 2020 era of the
pandemic there was this plot to kidnap
the democratic michigan governor
gretchen whitmer and a number of people
were arrested for that we have now
learned what the consequences will be
for one of the uh co-conspirators i
guess we would call them there a
michigan man who admitted to taking part
in an extremist group's plot to kidnap
gretchen whitmer in retaliation for
covid restrictions was sentenced
yesterday to over six years in prison
the man is 25 year old ty garbin is the
only person to have pleaded guilty out
of the more than a dozen men facing
state and federal charges stemming from
the plot so understand that this guy got
more than six years
he pleaded guilty and cooperated the
others are presumably going to trial
and
this guy still got six years so just
think about what might be coming for
some of the other individuals here
uh five of those charged in federal
court pleaded not guilty and faced trial
in october
u.s district judge robert jonker
sentenced garban to 75 months in prison
three years of probation and a 2500
dollar fine during the sentencing
hearing garben apologized to whitmer who
was not present this guy essentially
threw himself at the mercy of the court
pleaded guilty cooperated and apologized
and still got more than six years
at least in theory of course it'll
depend on exactly what charges all
others are convicted of if at all
you could be looking at way longer
prison sentences for the others um the
individual ty garvin said quote first i
would like to take this opportunity to
apologize to governor greta gretchen
whitmer and her family i've had a lot of
time to reflect on my actions and i
never realized what my actions would
have caused to her but also her family i
can't even imagine the amount of stress
and fear her family fem members felt
because of my actions and for that i am
truly sorry
garban also apologized to his friends
and family i never took into
consideration the emotional effect that
my actions would take on them and for
that i was truly selfish to not take
into consideration my family members
that have meant so much to me he
expressed the desire to continue to
de-radicalize himself
and help prevent others from becoming
radicalized and going down the same path
so that's great if that stuff is true it
very well might be completely
disingenuous and what his lawyer said
say this in order to get the lightest
possible sentence it doesn't really
matter he was willing to do it and what
i am so so two thoughts here basically
first of all
they have to throw the book at these
guys it has to be made very clear
that it is not uh it is not a
serious modern society
if you can plot to kidnap
one of the
uh
the top state official the governor
um and get away with the slap on the
wrist it can't happen and so this is a
guy who
expressed remorse genuine or
disingenuous i don't know but he
expressed remorse he cooperated
he
is getting all the right buzzwords i
want to radical de-radicalize myself and
i apologize to everybody
and pleaded guilty and more than six
years in prison he will now have to do
um the other 11 individuals and again
only some of those we we know sort of
the path
uh to trial that is taking place but the
other up to 11 individuals could they
end up with more than a decade in prison
we don't know we'll have to wait but
this is exactly the way that this needs
to be handled because this is
extraordinarily serious and
unfortunately you know the there's this
very similar dynamic with the january
six trump rioters and we've started to
see some of those sentences come in we
covered one on the bonus show two three
maybe it was more like four weeks ago
and we can kind of argue over okay eight
years 12 6 15 and then if for good
behavior and prison overcrowding they'll
probably serve half
whatever ultimately is the number of
days and weeks and months that these
individuals serve it has to be made very
clear
that uh this is what they did on january
6th was worse
than just showing up and trespassing at
a business right like on paper the
literal charges that might be there
isolated from the political reality and
the movement and the mob mentality that
that
was part of what was going on
might not be as bad as 10 12 years in
prison
but that the overall event that they
participated in and its relationship to
having a functioning democracy etc
makes it worse there's sort of an
enhancement component there that has to
be taken into consideration and i hope
that we see the book thrown at the trump
rioters from january 6th as much as
hopefully the book will continue to be
thrown at the accused here if they are
found guilty of course or if they strike
plea deals when it comes to the plot to
kidnap governor gretchen whitmer and
it's it's actually crazy that because of
all the different things that were going
on at this time and because of the
complete daily scandal of the trump
administration at the time that this was
going on
this also this feels like it was a
relatively minor story and a long time
ago but this is this is crazy this is
crazy a concerted effort to kidnap a
governor and uh so far one down and many
more to go um ty garbin will have to
spend more than six years in prison
maybe only three for good behavior right
we'll have to see about that but we'll
continue to follow other sentences that
come forward